The last view I'd like to talk about is not really a view but a miscellaneous
category indicating that there's a lot of other information having to do
with system structure that hasn't been conveyed by the other views we've seen.
Okay? This has to do with supporting software in files which are, are,
are part of the system but maybe aren't part directly of the executing software.
Okay?
And I'm suggesting that this information be conpeyed, conveyed in,
in tabular text it includes things like installation scripts, log file analysis,
statistical processing, the make files that are there the configuration files
for different configurations for the system, any documentation.
Okay, the project manifests which describe system structure as part of a,
a large delivery package.
And any supporting tools.
Okay, when you're building the system all of these pieces have to
actually be there to contribute to the build and
hence they're part of this kind of grander architecture of a system.